mcconnell el líder de los republicanos
en el congreso es por estos días una
figura de contrapeso para el presidente
de la cndh trump mcconnell quien aceptó
la derrota del magnate ante yo bailé en
las elecciones de noviembre
ahora bloqueó una propuesta del
mandatario en el congreso el legislador
dejó en el limbo la votación sobre
aumentar de 600 a 2.000 dólares la
cuantía de ayuda para los
estadounidenses que se encuentra dentro
de un paquete de alivio contra la
pandemia sin dar una fecha concreta
mcconnell afirmó que el senado abordaría
este tema junto con otras dos propuestas
del mandatario el líder republicano
también está promoviendo una votación
para pasar por encima del veto
presidencial de champ sobre el
presupuesto de defensa un proyecto
aprobado anualmente desde hace 60 años
por los valientes hombres y mujeres de
las fuerzas armadas de eeuu
el fracaso simplemente no es una opción
así que cuando es nuestro turno y el
congreso sostiene sus espaldas el
fracaso tampoco es una opción
y trump a través de twitter confirmó lo
que parece ser una guerra abierta con
los republicanos del congreso dos mil
dólares para nuestro gran pueblo no 600
han sufrido suficiente por el virus
chino el liderazgo republicano débil y
fatigado permitirá que la mala ley de
defensa sea aprobada esta disputa llega
a falta de apenas una semana para que
georgia repita unas elecciones que
tienen dos escaños del senado en juego y
que decidirán qué partido controla esta
sala una coyuntura electoral que puede
convertir ese aumento de la ayuda en
importantes votos